welcome to Buddha Shanghai's hottest
real estate ground zero of China's
economic clout a forest of skyscrapers
proclaiming Shanghai's drive to become
Asia's financial capital but there's a
new mega structure rising on Pudong
Vlach 2,000 workers are toiling day and
night to build the Shanghai World
Financial Center and they won't stop
until it's 101 storeys tall
soaring nearly 500 meters into the sky
the tallest building on the Chinese
mainland and the third tallest building
in the world 17,000 people will work
inside it's 70 office floors topped by a
14 story luxury hotel and crowned by the
world's highest observation deck
building anything this big is not for
the faint of heart thanks to its modular
outrigger truss design workers are
building the world financial center at a
rate of one floor every three days
at the top the steel crew bolts in floor
plates completing the skeleton of the
91st floor meanwhile the cranes are
lifting a much lighter but critically
important load to the 90th floor where
another team begins the back-breaking
task of installing 10 meter lengths of
rebar over the steel floor plates next
step pour the concrete 90 floors below
what looks like a giant praying mantis
seems ready to attack the world
financial center in fact it's a concrete
pumping machine when the rebars ready
workers 400 meters high will need
massive amounts of concrete pumped up to
them to pull that off you need some of
the most powerful concrete pumps in the
world you're made small harp in the
uppermost pumping concrete from the
ground to the top of the building takes
a long time and if we don't mix it right
the concrete will set inside the pipe
and we'll waste a lot of time searching
for the blockage only Tiger wanna do
those of you know you talk to another
one they're wrong sighs you go
[Music]
you could fill an olympic-sized swimming
pool with the amount of concrete that
covers just one financial center floor
after the steel rebar and concrete you'd
think the toughest parts of building
this mega structure would be over but
one of the hardest jobs of all can't
even start until they're done installing
ten thousand windows me go Sheldon
median on average the group can install
about 15 windows per day we complete one
floor every three to four and half days
there you go finding schools in World
Financial Center windows are taller than
a basketball hoop and weigh as much as
three grand pianos add these Heights
wrestling with weights like that can be
dangerous
a crane hoists every window unit from
the ground and work teams position and
bolt them into place not just anyone can
do this job a highly trained team of 130
workers specializes in installing these
massive windows
job hopefuls with altitude issues need
not apply
step one attach the frames to a winch
then slide them out over the side
step two turn the window unit 180
degrees not an easy task if the wind is
blowing
step 3
workers suspended on the side of the
building help ease the window down to
the floor below and bolt it to brackets
already in place
step four repeat steps one through three
9999 times